Hey, what's up Avery?
>> Welcome back. Nor,
>> what's uh what's the claim you was
making in the day that the prophet
Muhammad has false prophecies?
>> Yeah, he uh gives a a prophecy that the
last hour would come in the lifetime of
a young boy named Muhammad that was
there in his in century.
>> What had is that?
>> Uh Sah Muslim 2953A.
>> Sah Muslim 2953A.
>> Yes, sir.
>> All right. It says, hold up. It says
narrated by Annis ib Malik. A man asked
the messenger of Allah subhana wa tala
when will the hour be the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam looked at a
young boy who was with him and said if
this boy lives he will not grow very old
until the hour comes upon you. Do you
know what hour this is talking about
Avery?
>> It says the last hour.
>> Yeah I know it says the last hour but do
you know what the Arabic word for hour
is? This terminology?
>> Yeah the the last hour refers to
judgment day. That's that's that's
literally the that's literally the title
of uh the the
>> Yeah, I understand what you're saying,
but that's that's you're presupposing
what that means. That the Arabic word is
assa. It means also personal death, a
people's destruction, or a massive
upheaval.
>> No, it doesn't.
>> Okay. If it doesn't, then let's pull it
on the screen and look at the Arabic
definition of it then. If you're telling
me it only has one meaning,
>> well, I got it right here. So um if when
they when they said when they say that
they asked the prophet when the last
hour would come, what were they asking
him?
>> So he's what he's saying is is that when
the young boy before he not not that
part I'm talking about when they came
and asked him when they said hey when
would the last hour come? What were they
asking him about?
>> I mean what they could have been asking
and what he answered could have been two
different things.
>> I understand. So what were they asking
him?
>> All right. They said a man asks the
messenger of Allah when will the hour
be? It says the last hour.
>> That's what I'm looking at here.
>> It says the last hour, bro.
>> What What narration are you looking at?
>> 2953.
29.
>> Let me pull up Muslim. Let me pull up
Sah Muslim real fast. 2953A.
>> Mhm.
>> And it's reported that a person asked
Allah's messenger as to when the last
hour would come. He had in his presence
a young boy of the Ansar who was called
Muhammad. Allah's messenger said if this
young boy lives he may not grow very old
till he would see the last hour coming
to you.
>> So they're asking about the last hour
not any personal hour. They're asking
about judgment day bro which is
literally look the t even the title of
the book that this hadith is in is the
book of tribulations importance of the
last hour. It's talking about judgment
day
>> right? So it definitely when he gave the
answer he was referring to the last hour
to them and there's multiple different
major events that happened during the
time within a 80year span while that
young boy while that boy would have
still been young too old many different
things that happened. So, even though I
know you're trying to equate it to the
uh the last the judgment day, it doesn't
necessarily mean the judgment day. And
like I was just trying to explain,
>> I'm ask I'm going ask you again. What is
the last hour?
>> I'm going to tell you again. The last
hour doesn't only equate to the judgment
day.
>> Okay. What is this hadith in the context
of
>> the hour?
>> What hour?
>> The last hour,
>> which is
>> it doesn't necessarily mean the final
day of judgment for all creation.
>> I'm ask you again.
When the book of this hadith
>> I'm counting this.
>> Well, no. I I I I'm trying to help you
comprehend this. When it says that the
book this this hadith is in the book of
tribulations and portance importance of
the last hour, what is that?
>> Oh, what did you just read?
>> I read the title of the hadith, the book
that it's in. You know how different,
you know how different hadiths are in
certain books within the collection,
>> right? So this hadith is in the chapter
or the book called the book of
tribulations and portance portance of
the last hour. What is that? What is the
last hour according to the title? What
is it talking about?
>> Right. So there so there are different
categories of last hour. That's why I
was trying to explain to you. So even
though
>> can you can you show me in the hadith
where it gives a last hour that's in
pertaining to somebody's personal death?
>> Yeah, I could I could absolutely show
you. So like I explained to you that
with it like within 80 years there were
multiple different major events that
happened while some of these people were
still alive even particularly companion.
>> You didn't you didn't hear my maybe you
didn't understand my question. Do you
have a hadith in this collection of
hadith in this context in the same book
where the last hour is not pertaining to
judgment day but it's pertaining to
somebody's personal death. If if if you
want me to quote scholarship, I can
quote email.
>> I don't care about scholarship. I care
about what the scholars can prove.
>> Do you an internal critique?
>> What what I'm doing? What I'm doing is
look, get quoting me a scholar appealing
to an authority is not an internal
critique. That is, hey, this scholar
said this. Okay. Why should I believe
what the scholar said? Does he have
evidence providing what he's saying? No,
he doesn't. If he doesn't have what I'm
asking for, then I have no reason to
just believe some ad hoc interpretation
for some from somebody who has a motive
to try to duct tape this, put a band-aid
on this error. You get what I'm saying?
I'm a critical thinker. So like I said,
I have no reason to believe, no evidence
whatsoever that the last hour in the
context of Islam period, especially in
the context of this hadith collection
and this chapter that the last hour has
anything to do with other than judgment
day. Can you show me any hadith in this
chapter in regards to the last hour
that's pertaining to sub pertaining to
somebody's personal death when it
mentions the last hour? Do you have
that?
>> I mean, yeah, I can definitely pull up
other hadiths that mention the events
that I'm about to bring up to you, but
you got to stop equivocating.
>> What What do you think I'm asking? What
do you think I'm asking for? Cuz it
sounds like you still didn't understand
what I'm asking. Now, either you're
purposely not doing it or maybe you
genuinely don't get what I'm asking.
You're you're asking for a hadith that
explains this hadith, right? Am I wrong
about that?
>> Guys, maybe maybe it's just me. Hold on.
Let me just address the audience. Ladies
and gentlemen, when I have these
conversations with my fellow human
beings, these fellow image bearsers of
God, they have they they were made in
the image of God just like all of us.
God loves them the same way he loves us.
Are my questions difficult, guys? When I
ask the question, be honest. When I ask
the question and the words come out of
my mouth, is the information
communicated in what is coming out of my
mouth difficult to understand? No, it's
pretty simple. All right, we got
thousands of people saying that what I'm
saying is pretty simple, quite
understandable. But for some,
>> I mean, it's okay that you have
thousands of sheep that are blind and
deaf. They have no idea. They follow
blindly.
>> The irony.
>> Oh my god.
>> They they follow you blindly.
>> The irony.
Oh my god. The Did that just come out of
your mouth? Did you just call these
people blind sheep?
>> You you you as a Muslim who think
Muhammad is a prophet of God. Somebody
else blind sheep. No. No, you're not.
No, you're not.
>> I think you just don't really like the
answers that come to you. You don't you
don't like them. That's what the problem
is.
>> I'm not going to lie. You're right. you
cuz we we explain to you plenty of times
what certain things mean and they're
coming from and and they're not coming
from just us just off the top of our
heads. We're telling you
>> now that's where I got to stop you. That
see see
>> I'm telling you from from scholarship.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Now that Nory, my
brother, that's where I got to stop you.
See, I agree with you in the beginning.
I agreed that I don't like your answers.
I agreed with you that you guys be
explaining stuff. I agree. Y'all be
talking. Y'all be explaining things that
I didn't ask about. Y'all be explaining
something. It's just not what I asked.
And y'all just be talking and shuffling
and waffling. I agree that you guys just
talk, think you're explaining things.
And you're right. I don't like the
answers you give because they have no
basis. They have no substance. They have
no logic to them, no reasoning to them.
They're ad hoc. Now, hold on. Where I
disagree with what you said is where you
just said that you just don't be making
up these answers off the top of your
head.
>> Yeah, you do. You guys are the kings and
queens of apo of a apologetic improv.
The quick the kings and queens. I mean
on the I've never seen nothing like it
on the spot. I've never seen Jehovah's
Witnesses do it as skillfully. Mormons
do it as skillfully. Not even atheists
do it as skillfully. Muslims deserve a
trophy for how you guys can come up with
a non-answer on the spot, bro. I
promise.
>> Okay. All right. hear my answer and then
I want you to break down. I want you to
to to
disassemble it and you tell me why you
don't accept the answer.
>> Go ahead.
>> That way I have a better understanding.
I want to come to some common ground
with you, Avery. I really want to
understand where you're where this I'm
not going to call it God logic because
God isn't a a god of confusion and it
seems like all you'd have with you.
>> Paul, stop quoting Paul. Yeah. I I Well,
not all of your Bible is false.
>> Oh, so Paul So Paul Paul has is a true
messenger then. He has some of his me
there's some things Paul could have said
that I could agree with.
>> Okay.
>> But like so I'm about to give you I'm
going to give you a list of things
events that happened after this this
this hadith was revealed and tell me
what about this don't co coincide with
what he said. Go ahead. cuz he told you
that before the young boy grows old the
hour will come near. So we have the
prophet passing away in 11 ah. We have
the great fitna war that happened
between 35 and 40 ah. We had we had
major battles like cifin and jamal. We
had the martyrdom of Usman Ali and
Hussein. We had massive political
upheaval and within 80 years almost all
of the companions were gone. So, how
does that not apply to a certain hour
for the Uma?
>> Awesome stuff. You know what? I I
honestly don't even know where I'mma go
from here. I don't even know where I'm
going to go. You know what?
>> Of course you do. You know what? Of
course you do.
>> You know, you know what that I'mma just
do I'm going just do the only thing I
know how to do.
>> Hey man, come on man. Hey, I see you do
something all really often. I just would
like to have a full conversation one
day. We are a full conversation. Oh.
Hey, man. You be kicking me to the to
the curb, bro.
>> No, I'm not I'm not kicking you. I'm not
kicking you, bro. I'm not kicking you.
>> You be kicking me to the curb pretty
fast, man.
>> I'm not kicking you. You're You're not
>> guys. What What's the only thing I know
how to do, y'all? And they already got
it. The the audience is already quoting
on YouTube.
>> They're telling me watching my head. I
can duck with you.
>> No, that's that's what it is.
>> I told you last time I was up there. I
said you you got to be better than that.
You can't
>> listen look look at look at the comment
section. What look at what they're
telling you that I'mma do. That's the
only thing that I
>> saying is read. Oh, you want read.
>> That's it.
>> You want to read?
>> That's it, man. That's all I
>> So when you read, you don't interpret.
>> No, don't. No need, bro. No need. So,
look.
>> Oh, there's no need for interpretation.
>> No need.
>> Hey, man. You a slippery dude, man. You
a slippery dude. You sure you weren't at
them after parties, man?
>> Oh, wow.
>> Place got that baby oil on you.
>> Come on. Nah, man. No. I was
>> Let's stop for the law. I ain't going to
put that on you. I ain't going to put
>> Come on, man. Let's down.
>> All right. I ain't going to put I ain't
going to put that on you. I ain't going
to put that.
>> All right. Appreciate that.
>> Sorry. You ain't do no blaspheming so
far. So, we good.
>> Thank you.
>> The moment you say something crazy, I'm
a scadattlele. I'm telling you now.
>> I understand. All right. So, I'mma just
read and I'mma and I'mma give you the
answer to your question. The answer to
the question that you asked me was how
does everything that you just appealed
to and all those events happening over
that c that that that time span how does
that not coincide with a particular hour
that is was supposed to come right in
the in the lifetime of these people
right so let me just read and let the
hadith answer your question guys here it
is anas reported that a person asked
Allah Allah Paul's messenger, sorry. As
to when the last hour would come, what
did they ask about? Did they ask about a
particular hour? No. Well, yeah, the the
last hour. What hour did they ask about?
The last hour. Did they ask about when
the um is going to go through? Nope. Did
they ask about when am I going to die?
Nope. Did they say when is my last?
Nope. They said when is Al the last hour
going to come? And what Muhammad does is
he pauses for a second because he
doesn't know how to answer this
question, but then does what I said that
you guys are the best at. Comes up with
something on the spot. That apologetic
improv, that Islamic improv. It started
with a Muhammad. Watch how he comes with
this answer on the spot. He had a boy in
his presence and he looked at the boy
and the boy looked at him and Muhammad
looked at the boy and the young boy
looked back at him and Muhammad looked
back at the boy and then Muhammad looked
at the men asking the question. The men
asking the question looked at Muhammad
with curiosity. Muhammad looked back at
them with a stern face and said, "If if
this young boy lives, by Allah, he may
not grow very old till he sees the last
hour coming to you." That's what
happened. Now, this they asked about the
last hour. Muhammad answered them about
the last hour. And therefore,
talking to me about when somebody else
dies, talking to me about when somebody
else becomes the caiff, talking to me
about when Muhammad dies, has nothing to
do with what they asked and what
Muhammad answered. Muhammad is talking
about the last hour, judgment day. They
asked him about the last hour, which is
judgment day. The hadith is in context
of judgment day. The chapter is
literally called judgment day. The last
hour.
>> Hold on now. I got to stop you there
because you first of all let we have a
understanding here that you are reading
a English translation.
>> Not only not and not only are you
reading an English translation, you're
interpreting it through a English lens.
>> So the word cayama is really what it's
referring to when when it speaks about
judgment day. But when it's talking
about the last hour, it's speaking of
assa. So when I when like for example,
I'mma give you some examples here. So
there's another hadith and I'll give you
the hadith number. There's another
hadith where it says whoever dies um
whoever on the lives his kyama has
already started. So you can have the
kiama and you can have a minor kyama.
>> Agreed. So it's not so it's not only
speaking about
>> what is the kyama
>> the kyama that's what I'm trying to tell
you the even though I just how I said it
that minor kyama it's never worded minor
kyama it'll still say
>> kama no what is the what is the kyama
>> I mean in context we can say the kyama
is judgment day but you can also say the
kyama in a way where it's personal
>> all right I got you so look Nori answer
this question for me in context. What is
the last hour that they're talking?
>> Well, first of all, the hadith by itself
lacks the context to support your claim.
>> The hadith is in context with other
hadiths that are all about what? What is
what are what is this entire section of
hadith about? all talking they're all
talking about different variations of
the last hour
>> which is
>> which could be the last hour of a person
group or
>> no respectfully let's not go in circles
according to the section of I'm telling
you it's in categories
>> okay according to the section of hadith
does the last hour refer to anything
other than the judgment day please
answer honestly if you can't answer
honestly I'm going to move on
>> you no you're not going to look if you
want to force me to try to say no then I
mean I'm I'm not going to force you
anything. I want I'm trying to push you
to be honest. That's all.
>> So, be honest.
>> No, you're trying to You're trying to
push me to say what you want. All right.
Stop wasting time. Let's not waste time.
>> Just answer me straight away in this
section of hadith in this chapter about
judgment day.
>> Is there any hadith that refers to the
last hour other than it being the
judgment day? Yes or no?
>> Okay. One of them, one of them is the
one that you're reading and I can give
you more. One of them is the one that
you're reading.
>> Give me one hadith in this collection in
this section where it mentions the last
hour that's not talking about judgment
day. Give me one
>> in Sah Bkari Amed. They said, hold on,
>> brother. I'm in Sah Muslim in a
particular chapter and book in Sah
Muslim. Bro, you good?
>> Yeah, I'm here. I'm here. Just give me
one second. Okay.
>> Okay. No problem. Fine.
>> No problem.
>> Thank you. All right. Sorry about that.
Sorry about that.
>> It's okay.
>> All right. All right. So, all right. So,
I'll give you an example. So, and this
is going to be straight out of the
Quran.
>> Oh my gosh.
>> Okay. I know you're saying out of the
sahi out of sahi Muslim, but what I'm
trying to explain to you is that the
wording does not only apply to the last
judgment day. It doesn't it doesn't mean
that it only mean I'm going to say this
one last time. I'm going to say this one
last time, bro. And if you can't get it,
I'mma move on.
>> Go ahead, say it again, bro.
>> I'll say it again. I know that you're
appealing the context. What I need you
to do is show me contextually within
this book of Hadith in Sah Muslim,
chapter 54, the book of tribulations
importance of the last hour. I need you
to show me one hadith within that
section where it mentions the last hour
and it's not talking about judgment day.
It's talking about something else. Is
that clear? Do you understand what I'm
asking now?
>> Yeah, I I understand.
>> All right,
>> I understand.
>> So, I'll wait for that. Can get that
>> real fast.
>> All right.
>> Get it for you real fast.
>> All right. In the meantime, I'll go
ahead and start reading some super
chats. Thank you guys for the 3100
people that's watching on YouTube. Make
sure each and every one of you guys hit
the like button. It's a good day. As you
guys can see, my patience is much
thicker today. It's my birthday, so I'm
in a better mood than I guess usual.
But, uh, make sure you guys hit the like
button, man. And I hope that you guys
are learning, especially learning how to
uh deal with the circles that the
Muslims will try to take you when it
comes to certain arguments. I hope that
you guys are paying attention to when
Muslims try to come out the blue and
come with these random explanations and
ad hoc interpretations. Hold them to the
fire and make them prove focus and make
them prove what what you're asking them
to prove. All right? And this is how you
do it. Forget all this extra stuff.
Forget all of that.
Show me one hadith within this
collection that this hadith is in the
context of where the last hour is not
appealing is not talking about judgment
day. Show me one.
>> All right. Just one thing before I
answer.
>> You didn't have to read some of that
blasphemous stuff, man.
>> What blasphemous?
>> Even though it didn't come from you.
Even though it didn't come from you. I
mean, you didn't have to. You ain't have
to say that.
>> I just read in the super chats, man. I
didn't see anything blasphemous. So,
what's your answer?
>> So, you may not you may not accept it.
I'm cool with you not accepting it. cool
with not uh making any ground today. If
you want to drop me after it and not
touch any other topics, then that's your
prerogative. But what I will answer with
is that there is a separate example of
where the prophet peace be upon him said
the death of one of you is his hour
using the same wording that's from that
hadith sah.
>> Yeah, but it doesn't say the last hour.
So, so, so just to be clear in what I
asked you about all of those, all of
those hadith in that section, the last
hour is always pertaining to judgment
day. Is that correct?
>> No, it's not. That's not correct.
>> So, you found a hadith in sahi Muslim
chapter 54, the book of tribulations,
importance of the last hour. You you
hadith number 282 2880 to 2955.
In those hadith, you found a hadith
where the last hours.
>> Give me those. Give me those numbers
again.
>> No, brother. You You got to come back in
another time, bro. You're wasting my
time. We can talk about something else
next. Why don't
>> you get to another topic? When'd you get
to another topic then?
>> Because you showed me that you're too
dishonest to go with this topic. So, we
can't talk about something else.
>> No, you just don't accept the answers. I
literally told you that it doesn't only
apply to that.
>> Thank you. Take care, man. Appreciate
it.